Barry your speed it's getting worse!
I'm barely hanging on I can't catch my
breath all I can think about is if I'll
be fast enough to save another life
Flash is losing his speed drain him of the rest.
Nash is taking control of
his pain you can't feed off of him anymore.
No!
[Screaming]
It's over Thawne.
The satellite scans say there are no
traces of thawne's negative tachyons to
be found in any organic matter on the
planet. As four Nash, Cecile says she'll confirm
that she didn't feel any of thawne's
energy inside him. According to
three-dimensional imaging Nash's brain
waves are Thawne free.
I guess this means STAR Labs
has successfully completed its
very first exorcism. Thawne's gone for now.
Right, Thawne's tachyons might have
dissipated but they weren't destroyed.
Which means he's not dead, just
formless. He's probably out there looking
for another body right now like a
red-eyed pissed-off Voldemort. When he comes
back we'll be ready.
I'm gonna go check on Nash
are you ah, you guys make up yet mm-hmm
thank God
guys are we sure creating an artificial
Speed Force is the way to go
I mean anyone who came in contact with
Thawne's speed force got hurt. Ours will be
different. Yeah but we still don't even
know where to start.
Actually I do.
Every time Thawne tried to
hurt me using Nora's memory.
Really what he did was reminded me how much I loved her.
Made me realize that she's the
answer
Nora's Journal. Thawne taught nor how to
build a speed force.
Now she can teach us.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my flash season 6 episode 16
trailer video and explain her for what
was going on with Barry creating the new
Speed Force reverse flash so we'll break
it all down there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs from episode 15 - if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a new
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your biggest theory about what's going to
happen with this new Speed Force on the
video what could possibly go wrong
Barry creating his own Speed Force you
also probably saw the announcement
Stephen Amell made on his Instagram
livestream that he was never coming back
to the air over he said he never cross
over to any of the other shows or guest
star anymore he said nope I'm done with
that everyone post all your spongebob
memes because that's exactly what he
just did they also just changed the
schedule for the flash episodes because
of all the craziness with the virus and
the quarantines that are going on right
now they had to stop production hard
stop so they might not even finish the
rest of the season on the flash but
we'll find out more about that pretty
soon so we'll just start with the
episode 15 big Easter eggs and then I'll
talk about the episode 16 footage The
Exorcism of Nash wells everyone
wondering what's the deal with the
reverse-flash why wasn't he around
during crisis on Infinite Earths how did
he come back this time in what's
happening with him next thankfully they
did not fridge him as a character in the
episode he's still out there like Barry
and Cisco say his energy just looking
for another body to inhabit the really
cool thing that I'm glad that they did
they're actually being accurate to the
comics when they talking about this
because when speedsters die technically
they don't die like regular people
normally they become pure Speed Force
energy and just returned to the Speed
Force like before the Speed Force died
because Barry poisoned it with the
specter energy earth 90 Barry Allen
sacrifices himself during crisis on
Infinite Earths seemingly turns into
nothingness his body was actually just
becoming pure Speed Force so had the
Speed Force not been poisoned you could
actually go into the Speed Force and
talk to his consciousness because
reverse-flash relies on the negative
Speed Force it's the same idea it's just
that his body would just go into the
negative Speed Force once he died once
he lost his physical form so he's just
floating around the negative Speed Force
looking for someone else to attach
himself to
I don't know if he's going to inhabit
another version of Wells and they're
going to keep it as Tom Cavanagh or they're
going to use this as an opportunity to have
him inhabit someone else's body
and introduce a new looking version of
reverse-flash they kind of did that with
earth Prime like we have the new version
of Muir Master Cisco's brand-new pokedex
of all the different villains that have
been changed since crisis on Infinite
Earths some of them look very different
some of them are kind of the same though
but the episode was mostly about
explaining what's going on with the
alternate version of the wells from the
multiverse inside Nash wells head so the
idea is is that they'll continue to
exist they're just bound to him because
of what happened with them rebooting the
universe during crisis on Infinite
Earths they also give you Nash wells
backstory and how he met Allegra's
doppelganger and kind of adopted her as
his surrogate daughter he's kind of like
a cross between Nathan Drake from
uncharted and Indiana Jones just
searching for artifacts all over the
multiverse except he's hunting for
artifacts that mostly seem like they're
referencing the New Gods Darkseid in the
monitor from the look of those symbols I
don't know if they have any plans to use
any new gods related characters because
there's a big new gods DC movie that's
going to happen in a couple years by the
time that movie happens the flash might
be off the air so it might be a
non-issue but the flash right now is
kind of like all might from my hero
academia slowly losing his power they're
going to use Nora's original journal from
before her time line was white to create
a new alternate version of the Speed
Force remember the reason why her
journal survived is because it's written
in a language that's impervious to
changes to the timeline so they're going to
use the same techniques that she used to
enter the negative Speed Force and study
the Speed Force with reverse flashes
help so they're kind of going off of
reverse flashes notes in a sense or the
things that he taught to Nora there's a
lot of flash rebirth comic book
storyline going on here on the TV show
from the force quest storyline recently
so I'm hoping on par with that it will
lead to Barry going super saiyan flash
no joke
they actually dropped the legit Dragon
Ball Z reference during the flash comic
book recently and it was all about Barry
just sort of sucking up all of the Speed
Force because of the different numbers
of forces that had been revealed when
they broke this quote-unquote barrier
whatever the TV show does with that it's
going to be a little bit different from the
comics so I don't know if they're going
to
do all the different forces from the
comics but I do think that they're
headed for Barry slowly losing his power
like the trailer for next week's episode
the title is actually so long and
goodnight the title of that episode is a
reference to Barry losing the last of
his Speed Force energy in his body it's
kind of like all might losing the last
embers of one for all after going United
States of smash so bring me back around
to Super Saiyans Dragon Ball Z Dragon
Ball super references
every time Goku achieves a new level of
power it's usually right after he almost
dies or seemingly dies really good
example is during the tournament of
Power Dragon Ball super he fought jiren
seemingly died after he created a spirit
bomb his energy disappeared everyone
thought that he had been obliterated but
really just turns out that he'd absorbed
the energy from his spirit bomb and used
it to temporarily go ultra instinct for
the first time so think of the flash is
being on the path to going ultra
instinct flash but only temporarily the
next episode isn't going to air till April
7th that's because all the virus in the
quarantine II I think he's just taking
them longer to get the episode out and
then there's no new episodes after that
indefinitely until everybody goes back
to work I think we'll hear more about
that in the next couple of weeks
the footage of ragdoll coming for Joe
West is all about the black hole
storyline black hole orders a hit on Joe
West the deal with Muir masters that
she's still trying to escape the mirror
dimension even though for some reason
she can send other things through the
mirror she herself seems like she's
trapped inside the mirror dimension
she's using all these devices from the
real world bringing them back in so that
she can escape my assumption based on
the footage with her wanting to drain
the last of the Flash's speed force
energy just has something to do with her
escaping the mirror dimension and
preventing him from stopping her but I
think it's all in service of giving her
more backstory so that when they pay off
they have this big final battle it's a
little more meaningful you didn't get
too much backstory with the Sam Scudder
mere master it has for Stephen Amell has
comments about never coming back he
could just be bargaining with the
network like you know what if you want
me to come back you're going to have to pay
me a ton of extra money to come back but
we'll see I was just really surprised by
the way he was so frank about it like
nope I'm done I think I did that for
eight years I'm good no more peace I'm
out of here but what'll happen is is
because everything kind of shut down for
the next couple of weeks in Hall
TV's and movies because of the
quarantine and all the craziness with
the virus I'll post more updates when we
get more information about what's going to
happen next
some people will still be airing
episodes of TV some stuff will be on
break so I'll just post updates based on
the videos that I do so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see all those videos when I post
them but if you have any big questions
or big theories just post them on the
video reminder our next episode of the
flash comes April 7th then after that
they might have another break but
they've already filmed up to episode 18
or 19 so they do have more episodes that
they can just finish in post-production
and air but there might be one or two
episodes that they have to cut off we
probably won't find out about that for a
while
everyone click here for my new
spider-man 3 marvel video learn about
the Marvel Netflix characters coming
back and click here for my video about
all the canceled and delayed movies
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!